so I was watching this Woody Allen film
called Hannah and her sisters and in the
movie there's this scene where Michael
Kane's character Elliot is sitting at
the dinner table with his wife Hannah
now Elliot is completely emotionally
detached he is Disturbed and that's
because he's been having an affair with
his wife's sister shocking stuff I know
but this scene really got me thinking
about the way in which a lot of us live
our entire lives hopefully not by having
affairs with our wife's sisters but what
I mean is that we do certain things or
leave certain things undone in the past
that continue to eat away at us
subconsciously in the present and a lot
of the time we do this so compulsively
that we don't even know that we're doing
it we just see it as normal we don't
know anything else yet we're living a
lower quality of life because of it
every single thing that we do every
single conversation that we have is
infected by the things that we've left
usually really undone in the past and I
think this is the most insidiously toxic
thing about escapism and procrastination
and that is because of something I like
to call mental air time when we haven't
yet done what we know we're supposed to
do and we have a tendency to put these
things off every single day
then we exist in a mental framework
where we are a person who hasn't yet
done the thing that we're supposed to do
and over a long period of time this
really changes how we feel about our
entire lives because no matter what
we're doing no matter what kind of
conversation we're having no matter how
special the person we're having that
conversation with is we are
subconsciously tainted by the fact that
we are not where we're supposed to be we
are not being who we're supposed to be
and we live our entire lives like this
emotionally disturbed with this feeling
of anxiety that's just always there
because of our chronic escapism people
don't talk about procrastination this
way it's nuts because when we
procrastinate it's not just the thing
that we're supposed to do that suffers
everything else suffers as well because
we're not present with it we don't have
the mental capacity to enjoy it anything
good in our lives is infected with this
feeling like it's not good enough we're
not supposed to be here because there's
that other thing that we're supposed to
be doing and the weird thing is it's not
like we're never going to do that thing
we usually end up doing it usually the
deadline comes closer the repercussions
for not doing it grow scarier and more
acute so we eventually guilt ourselves
into eventually doing it so that we can
repeat that cycle every single day for
the rest of our lives but what's crazy
is since we end up doing it anyways
there's great utility to just changing
the order in which we do things we can
escape and do all of the other [ __ ]
later but if we could find a way to do
the most important thing that we need to
do earlier in the day then we could
change the entire Narrative of Our Lives
we could change the way we feel about
ourselves about our capability to solve
problems and the theme of Our Lives
that's echoing through our subconscious
becomes oh
yes I can play video games I can watch
this movie I can enjoy this conversation
because I've already done the thing that
I'm supposed to do so how do we do it
that's the golden question well knowing
what it's doing to us is great and I
think this will help you get some
motivation to just do the damn thing but
when push comes to shove this is an
irrational problem I can give you all
the rationality in the world but when
you're faced with the crossroads of
watching this funny little YouTube video
versus writing a research paper
something other than logic takes over
your monkey brain kind of bullies your
rational brain into coming up with a
rationalization to justify some
sub-optimal Behavior so the answer can't
be logical it has to be an emotional
tactic and I think that tactic is
submission submission
foreign
nobody talks about this word submission
in a productivity context they talk
about it in other contexts but we're not
going to get into those other contexts
that's not what this channel is about
what I mean by submission it is a
feeling of melting into what you're
supposed to be doing it's not increasing
the tension in your body to try to fight
and Bully your monkey brain into doing
what your more logical side of your
brain wants it to do no it's
acknowledging
that doing what you're supposed to do
feels difficult it's feeling that
tension that's stopping you from doing
that thing and letting go of it and
doing the thing anyways we need to get
good at shutting the brain off
stopping the chatter of rationalization
and escapism reduce the tension in our
body take a deep breath and just do the
thing we can think about all the
rationalizations afterwards but
submitting to what you already know
you're supposed to be doing is less of a
psychological feeling it's more of a
physiological feeling and again this
might sound very woo-woo but if you've
ever tried to take cold showers or go
cliff jumping with your friends it's the
same feeling you almost submit to the
discomfort if you're standing there at
the edge of the cliff and you don't want
to jump even though you know it's
perfectly safe it's a very steep drop
off very deep water nothing could happen
to you
you almost need to just submit to the
gravity same thing with cold showers if
you already know you're going to enter
into the cold shower and feel very
uncomfortable the only way that you're
going to get in there is if you just
walk in you stop the chatter you stop
thinking the mind is corrosive it'll try
to figure out all these different little
ways to weasel out of it and you don't
end up doing it it's like if you already
know this is what you must do
relax your body and submit to it and
while you're in the cold shower it feels
so much colder if you maintain this
resistance if you try to fight the cold
if you tense up your body and you try to
like convince yourself to power through
it it's so much better if you just
concentrate on the cold you fully submit
to it you fully focus on it and you
accept the fact that it's cold and then
it ceases to be so cold you're allowing
yourself to relax into this discomfort
it actually feels quite euphoric when
you do that I think this is the key to
stop procrastinating I think this is the
key to make better decisions in the
moment you've already heard the logical
reasons as to why you should do the
thing that you're supposed to do you
know that your life will be dramatically
better if the majority of the time you
spend here on this Earth you exist in a
headspace where you have already done
the most important thing that you need
to do you already know that this is so
good for you the only step now is when
you're confronted with the crossroads is
to just turn the brain off to submit to
what you're supposed to do it's like
submitting to the highest version of
yourself and you start to develop trust
that that highest version of yourself
has your best interest in mind
so if you are now motivated and excited
to submit to your destiny and you want
further reading or other resources that
will help you do that then I highly
recommend the audiobook The One Thing by
Gary Keller which is an audiobook I
frequently revisit using today's video
sponsor audible because that book really
talks about a lot of the things that I
talked about in this video it's about
distilling down all of these things that
you have to do into this important thing
and it helps you tackle doing this thing
as early as possible so that you can
live the rest of your day having already
done this thing and having that very
narrative change your entire life and
for those of you who don't know audible
is the leading provider of spoken word
entertainment and audiobooks all in one
place every single month they send you
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audiobook
forever if you ever cancel your
subscription for any reason at any point
you still keep your entire library of
audiobooks including the audiobooks that
you got for free using their credit
system audible members also get instant
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible Originals podcasts and exclusive
Series so if you're interested in
joining me in becoming big brained and
soaking in information from people who
are a lot smarter than I am than if you
use my link in the description below
you'll get a 30-day free trial so you
can download the one thing by Gary
Keller right now
within one minute you can also just text
better ideas to 500 500. so once again
to sign up for your 30-day free trial
click my link in the description below
go to audible.com better ideas or text
better ideas to 500 500. thanks again to
Audible for sponsoring this video if you
liked this video and you got a lot out
of it then consider actually hitting the
like button because when you hit the
like button the algorithm blesses Me by
shoving my bald head into other people's
home pages helping them out which also
helps me out so it's a win-win for
everybody involved you get to spread the
love of
ideas and goodness and big brainness
with other people and that's just
fantastic why wouldn't you want to do
that if you're lurking here and this is
the thousandth brazilianth time that
you've seen my face consider hitting the
Subscribe button other than that thank
you so much for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video